all right guys
bang bang i'm really really excited to
have chris here today so thanks so much
for doing this sir
thank you so much for having me palm
excited to be here absolutely
uh i have been drinking athletic greens
now for a while
uh and as people who listen to the
podcast know i almost never
ever talk about anything that uh i put
in my body other than uh
than dominoes on every saturday uh but i
gotta say that uh
it has quickly become a a staple um
so i'm excited to kind of hear the story
but maybe let's get into
your background first uh you got an
accent so
uh you're not coming from uh from the
united states uh where'd you grow up and
kind of what'd you do before athletic
greets
well thank you for the kind words mate
so i'm from new zealand i have the
monaco kiwi because when i first moved
to the us
people kept saying which chris kiwi
chris and it just kind of became kiwi
and kind of sweet after i got about
fighting it and just went [ __ ] it
i'll go with kiwi and it's stuck
particularly in the
north american environment but i'm from
new zealand my parents are world
travelers i
i had seven years in japan growing up
i'd been to 43 44 countries by time i
was 12
13 traveled the world and but had most
of my adolescent years growing up
in new zealand and went had an obsession
with being bruce lee
sport all those typical fun things you
do when you're a teenager and
ended up going to auckland university
and studying for a bachelor of science
in sport and exercise science which
has been my lifelong passion has been
that health and fitness piece i dropped
out of that
to start a supplement company which went
under and i promptly felt sorry for
myself and did odd jobs
for a number of years before eventually
returning to the entrepreneurial journey
always with a passion for health and
fitness but my
first sort of forays back in the
business weren't health and fitness
related they were
property and finance related and
continued reading learning always
thinking i was up to date on the health
and fitness piece and
ended up really sick i was a pretty
competitive rugby player
played sport to a reasonable level i was
no great athlete by any means you
[ __ ] said to me man if you were
playing college football but
you get the piece was just living what i
thought was the correct manner
and applying sort of a 90 10 rule to how
i was living which was a 90
do everything right and in theory the
other 10 won't matter
and i got really sick i was continually
sick my whole life growing up i was
having three or four doses of
antibiotics
typically a year and eventually had a
catalyst where
um i was just sort of looking in the
mirror one day i was actually in uruguay
with some friends for on a holiday and
i've just gotten off the plane and
gotten sick again and
i heard someone yelling out where's the
kiwi and he's upstairs coughing and
someone like here's the black lung and
black lung stuck with me for two husband
bugger this i'm going to take ownership
of this and just go figure out what's
going on so that led me
down a sort of new journey all over
again
down the health and fitness piece i
ended up at a clinic in phoenix with
some very smart people running
tens of thousands of dollars of tests on
every blood stool test saliva test
that you can imagine that was about 2008
and on the
outside of that i ended up on a
customized
blood chemistry 100 a day sort of
supplement regime
and it turned out that i just wasn't
absorbing nutrients properly
and it just really challenged a lot of
my assumptions around what is good
health
how should we be eating how should we be
absorbing nutrients what does that even
look like and
the somewhat short version of that story
man as i ended up
putting a whole bunch of things into one
place together with the help of some
really smart people and formulating this
product
uh called athletic greens which i i
don't claim to be the key and king
scientist behind it i'm the entrepreneur
who put it together
and took it to market and made a lot of
mistakes along the way but i'm proud to
be
behind a do good brand to do good
business that a lot of people like
yourself
have adopted as a key daily habit and
sort of getting the benefit that i
originally wanted for myself so it's
been an interesting journey
for sure and i guess part of this is um
i'm fascinated by people who travel a
lot right and so when you were young
uh you kind of are in this weird
situation where
uh your parents dictate where you go
right what you eat where you go
everything about your life is uh is
these uh people's responsibility
uh yours took you around the world right
for all intents and purposes in terms of
a lot of uh
travel talk a little bit about how that
um
in hindsight kind of forms your world
perspective
and maybe the advantages that uh that it
gave you of
over other people who didn't have that
experience it's an interesting question
i've already mentioned
at other points uh in some of the other
interviews by the way i love your
podcast i only discovered it this year
mate and has become a staple
so thank you for just keeping your mind
so open as you explore your own growth
and also the areas that are interesting
to you i love listening
the look i won the lottery with my
parents i'm
just unbelievably grateful to the
phenomenal nuclear family i have and
their desire to expose us to different
experiences
luckily for me uh my dad
ended up getting an opportunity to go
first study and then work in japan so
we had this experience living in a
completely foreign culture at a time
when there still weren't that many
foreigners there
if you went to the boonies you sort of
pointed at and stared at
and laughed at i was this random blonde
head kid back then
and you're just gonna get an idea that
we are part of a
global citizenry and we have far more in
common than we have differences and
people are people and the vast majority
of people
are wonderful great warm people and that
was just reinforced in the nearly one
year backpacking we did
with my dad with his big pack my mum's
smaller backpack and just kept coming
down to my little sister's
like mini backpack and where we just got
exposed and they intentionally exposed
us to
multiple third world countries um
roughing it in backpackers
but also some some great experiences
with cultures and
in places like kenya and on some parts
of like cairo and the middle east so it
was really
amazing and it does open your eyes to
the commonalities
and it also made us
really good all of us at making friends
like everyone in my family is amazing at
making friends we're just interested to
see where the commonalities instantly
and my mother's probably the world's
best report builder
and and i i can't i can't say enough the
importance for young people to be
exposed to foreign cultures in a format
whereby they
are the guests in someone else's house
and society and just experience that as
an eye opener yeah and and so are there
any like uh specific memories you have
that you feel like were formative
uh moments during that time of travel
right there there are there are many i
can give you one a little bit later
because i've traveled
many times i was in morocco and
had just left a town called fes which is
this amazing medina walking into the
medina in
in morocco's like walking back 800 years
in the course of 100 meters but
i stopped on the side of the road and
asked two young girls for directions and
my girlfriend at the time
uh sort of said to them how do we get
from here to there and they told us and
they looked at each other and they just
said we'll show you
so these two girls jumped in the back of
our car
and we're driving towards this i think
we're going to the train station and now
where are you staying we don't have a
place that like you have to come to our
house so
they'd gone out and bought one breeder
we didn't know it was to feed the whole
family demanded that we come to their
house and it was kind of on the
waistband okay that's fine so we go in
they get out of the car dad and mum come
out and say these people
are gonna stay here and are they like
okay that's great that's fine so they
invite us into this house which is this
incredibly humble one-room
house it's just it's one room house the
toilet's a hole in the floor
the sort of the chairs in the house are
basically
beds that along the side of the wall
that they have squabs on that people sit
on during the day
and then they lie on and sleep during
the night they gave us that burrito
to eat we didn't know that was their
meal to be cut up um
like a loaf of bread with nutella i
didn't know i was allergic to wheat then
i
smashed the and then i started realizing
this these guys have literally given us
everything that they were tending to eat
tonight without a thought without
knowing us it would really touch me man
and
there's this lovely old guy living there
and just had this amazing cultural
experience and just realized the
hospital these people was just like
nothing else so the next morning
woke up took all these amazing photos on
rocked off got them all printed out
laminated posted up bought a ton of
nutella
like loaves and loaves of bread came
back and they did not want us
to give them any of the food they just
but man were they happy with the photos
and it was just this warm touching
experience and just maybe
you don't know and you don't know
anything until you've experienced
uh what life is like for someone else
who's less fortunate than you
and realize just how much humanity there
is to be shared with the world as
opposed to us versus them
i think that's an awesome story
it's uh it's also this thing i think of
just uh
it's really cool to see humans who don't
really speak the same language
come from different cultures just
genuinely want to help each other
right and and i think that's part of
part of the beauty of that story
yeah well i i don't know about yourself
man when you've gone traveling and
you've done a bit have you had some of
those experiences as well
yeah it's pretty crazy um all right
let's get into uh
athletic greens um one of the the key
pieces so
uh you and i haven't talked about this
before but uh up until
maybe two years ago i did everything
uh that you shouldn't do i drank all the
time
i barely slept didn't care what i ate
um i played football in college so it
was you know pretty much
healthy enough and could do whatever i
wanted and was a young guy
about two years ago though started to
become more interested in
the food i was putting my body sleeping
drinking water kind of all the
like really really basic stuff uh and
i the way i tell story now is like just
sleeping alone
right just sleeping eight hours a night
completely changed
everything just drinking enough water
right
just cutting out some of the garbage
like each one of these like
very small um changes had a massive
impact and so maybe talk a little bit
i've heard you say before like the
importance of the food specifically
right and kind of how that's the
the core value that uh many people just
when they don't understand two they
don't have the discipline to kind of
follow
but just how important uh before you get
into supplementation also stuff like
the importance of food to your overall
health and well-being
it's a good question interesting that
you've had that experience i wonder how
much
that was the catalyst of your now
now wife joining the pomp team i i would
suspect a fair amount
right so it's a great question it's
interesting how you've noticed that the
application of some core habits have
led to a compounding effect and i have a
couple of frameworks that i look at
sort of health and wellness and there's
two different pieces really one if you
consider an old-fashioned green the red
needle meter where you have dark green
on one side
and it kind of subtly gets lighter green
yellow then to bright red on the other
side and you can put on the dark green
side
youth and lack of
insults and then amount of time that
you've been doing
all the other things correctly that are
kind of in line with the way
we were ultimately designed and evolved
and on the other side the red side you
have
old age insults and then the amount of
time
you've had some many or other of these
different
pieces not the way they should be and
i think if you just consider this green
the red meter as you then take into
consideration
all the different buckets that you kind
of want to apply that are in line
with our evolutionary norm and i think
a lot of people don't truly realize the
impact
of cumulative insults where we're doing
things that aren't quite right
and the cumulative impact of like
repetitive
habits relatively small things but the
few things that ultimately
move that needle are done continuously
and you have everything
from sleep stress light exposure
vitamin d movement outdoor activity
how much you socialize uh your sense of
community
and then you have the whole food piece
and once you get into the food piece
you have um sort of the macro piece
which is where you may be eating
highly refined foods with proportions of
bad fats and far sugars way out of whack
with anything we should be
consuming and you have the micronutrient
piece and you have
things that might inflame you so just
kind of in broad strokes if you have
your macros lined up in such a way that
they don't destroy you from a sort of
metabolic health piece and you have your
micronutrients lined up in such a way
that you're absorbing or putting into
your mouth what you
kind of need to function properly and
then you have
uh the inflammatory pieces which which
is where you're either not eating or
eating sufficient things that lead to a
healthy inflammatory environment so
with those kind of things in mind you
then say okay how does
what you eat really impact and you might
say well
if you're continually screwing with your
your blood sugar
and you're eating things that tear up
your gut or inflame you for any reason
and you're not getting in enough quality
uh
typically protein and then clean
nutrition around the micronutrients
then you're in for a bit of a rough road
and i think when it comes to
like just understand those three things
are massive and they and they all tied
together and
with the athletic greens piece it's just
this understanding that
you need a lot of things in your body to
be working
correctly this idea that it's just the
big things protein caps fats or
isolatedly the various micronutrients
the vitamins and minerals and that
just kind of smash them in hodgepodge is
fine
it's been thoroughly thrown out and i
think the understanding is
much more around look you need to kind
of reduce the insults you make here
while maximizing
your body's ability to work properly
for an extended period of time and where
athletic greens comes in
and sort of this idea of whole
food-based nutrition comes in is
one without screwing the pooch on the
macronutrients
and the inflammation piece so just
consider metabolic health blood sugar
obesity on one side and the inflammatory
piece the other side
how do you make sure that your body's
getting
the smaller pieces the micronutrients it
needs and using them properly and
there's kind of three parts that you're
either
not getting enough in in your mouth
you're not consuming enough or you're
not absorbing enough
or your body body's not using them
properly and
any one of those three and i think most
people particularly if they have those
other different sort of buckets
misaligned
will be way off on a modern lifestyle in
nearly all of those three so
there's this principle of it's a
long-term principle of synergy and the
understanding of
i think a guy called bruce ames has a
theory on triage which is
if you're short of certain things or
some parts of your body aren't working
correctly
you are prone to strip and pull from
other areas to ensure your body's
prime directors of you if you will of
sort of surviving in basic reproductive
health are met but at long-term expense
of of other things and
what i think is sort of important to
people is to understand that i went and
formulated a product that really worked
hard
on making sure that you got enough in
your mouth that you absorbed it
and that inside your body most things
were working
they're all like getting gentle touches
to make things work as well as possible
but it's no holy grail food is first you
gotta
get everything lined up and then what
you've learned is that you actually need
to line up all these other buckets at
the same time so i'm just very
very quick to point out food is first
own your lifestyle pieces
there's no magic silver bullet and with
that underway
you can look to to move from sort of
surviving to thriving to really
optimizing whatever your outcome is
that makes sense man it makes a lot of
sense and i think part of what
um you know is always so funny to me is
uh you see somebody they'll go to the
gym right and they'll go
run two miles three miles and then they
get done and they go eat you know
a cheeseburger right and it's kind of
like you're uh
disconnecting you you know that you
should work out and expend energy and
sweat and
uh you feel good when you're done doing
it all these things but then you go and
you almost give back all of the the
benefit of it
immediately right and uh part of
uh what is i think the journey or the
learning
uh exercise for a lot of people is
how do i actually attack the
you know social health uh or mental
health stuff how do i attack the
nutrition side how do i track uh attack
the exercise side the sleep like
there's all of these different
components and
where i think the world is going and you
guys are obviously a leading example of
this
is uh helping people do this stuff
easier right so there's a lot of people
who you know
sat down and spent hours and hours and
hours and hours
over many many years learning every
intricate detail of everything that they
should know
and then trying to optimize their life
around it right the truth is just most
people don't have that time and energy
and
or self-motivation to go learn all of
that
instead what we're seeing is we're
seeing people take that knowledge right
basically package it into
very easy to use things
like athletic greens where you say look
we know that you need these you know 75
plus
vitamins minerals etc how do we make
this
something that people don't even have to
think about it right it's just we know
we're delivering it so maybe talk a
little bit
not so much about like the formula but
this idea of
building a product that regardless of
what's
in it you can actually make it usable
for people and
and kind of uh ensure that it's not a
okay i'll try it one time and then i
give up on it because it's just too too
difficult or too much friction in my
life
so it's a good well it's a good question
i can talk to that there's a couple of
pieces there as well so talk about your
buddy who probably rhymes like pomp two
years ago who goes to the gym
eats the cheeseburger and then maybe
sits down for 16 hours of a day
and you say okay what's he doing right
what's he doing wrong maybe he stays up
looking at a blue screen
until eleven o'clock at night and sleeps
five or six hours doesn't really care
uh just keeps pounds more coffee and
repeats now if you look at
that kind of piece i think you you can
say well what's he doing as a positive
input
go to gym exercise great post workout um
smashing a cheeseburger
and not so great the subsequent sitting
down all day
not good the staring at the screen until
late at night
not good and i think that it's
one of the elements i think that it's
important to understand that getting
your health
and your health span or your performance
kind of ducks in a row
requires both a basic willingness to
take
ownership of the outcome and then the
daily habits that actually make a
difference and
it's not really a case of do more and
more and more i love the bruce lee quote
like it's not daily increase it's daily
group decrease like hackway the
unessential
i am absolutely an essentialist at heart
and one of the things that
really pisses me off about the entire
industry that i'm in
is that most most of the brands out
there most business out there sell
ineffectual products in some cases
relatively harmful products
they try to drive just off trend they
don't really differentiate around
anything
and they don't really focus on solving
uh corporate
problems and if you walk into a whole
foods and look at a shelf in the
so-called supplement section
it's like 400 things and you have no
idea
uh what you should probably be taking
unless someone's told you to go in or
maybe a friend of yours said hey
go go and take this stuff so and whole
foods is
the world's come a long way in the 10
years since since we've been in business
in terms of getting better and better
quality and nutrients more readily
available in the supplement world i mean
it was serious
utter rubbish for a long time it still
is in most cases
so when i when i got people to help me
ultimately formulate athletic greens it
was i
want to get the super bundle supplement
and make it as
easy and simple as possible so instead
of my 100 horse pills a day
i want one thing a day and instead of a
whole bunch of relatively ineffectual
synthetic isolates i want to get
as many things working well together as
possible and this
massive nutrient dense this principle of
nutrient density is important
bolus of nutrition it does as many good
things for me as possible
in one go such that if i wasn't going to
do anything else
supplemental to my food and just take
one thing it would be this
and that's what we've built and that's
why i mean we have different groups of
people who who love us and
some are the high performance or the
athletic population some are the
go forward achievers who frequently are
centralist but
kind of want the best and the other is
the health or health span focus
focus folks who are looking really to
maximize health span and
many people are all three so that
essentialist principle
uh combined with it's the key daily
habits there's no
hack there's no shortcut there's it's
just
do the basics like it's like running a
basement do the basics well
and just daily execute daily on the key
habits that are actually going to make a
difference
and let those benefits compound
and its daily habits literally drive
success in
everything and health and nutrition is
no exception
yeah well one of the uh really
interesting parts
of health and nutrition in general to me
is it seems like there's
fads right they come they go uh many
times they're
ideas that are not new they've just been
repackaged under a new name
with some you know new leader who's kind
of pushing that
thought process but as we know with
let's say diets for example
uh most people think of them as a finite
amount of time so i'm going to go on a
diet for two weeks three you know uh
three months or whatever it is maybe
if there's an event that i want to go
right i'm in college and i'm going to go
on spring break or i've got
a wedding coming up or whatever it is
and so
just naturally kind of these event-based
uh
motivations obviously people will give
up once the event
kind of occurs but talk more about the
these fads and how kind of um
they either work or don't work and and
why
they attract people and kind of capture
the attention
and really kind of permeate through
society as you know whether it's uh
keto or something else yeah so i think
if you look at any diet do sure
there are commonalities and typically to
some degree
uh there's a short-term result that can
be felt or achieved if someone adopts it
so they get that early
dopamine hit that they're getting some
sort of success it could just be water
loss or it could actually be a little
bit of fat loss or it could be
they stop eating things that are
pro-inflammatory to them
causing them bloat up feel like crap or
anything else
uh combined with a relatively poor base
of like how people get most of their
nutritional information is from
sort of so-called mass media who
really largely don't know what they're
talking about when they throw out the
study shows this or whatever
and you just take one look at the study
and you know man this is scary and
people will send me those all the time
and say could you debunk or
or back this up but i think it's that
desire to be on top of the next best
thing combined with
the people who typically popularize not
all of those eating formats
are trying to monetize or build a sort
of a following around what they're doing
i think that's the
that's the real catch particularly when
one group or other begins to polarize
politically
against one of the others which is just
absolutely nuts if you actually look at
most of the successful eating formats
the commonalities just like us traveling
the world
and meeting other cultures and people
the commonalities far outweigh
the differences which is pretty much eat
whole foods
wherever you can don't eat too much
don't eat in a way that's going to make
you infamed
inflamed completely screw up your blood
sugar
and make sure you take off your
micronutrient basis whatever that looks
like
for you and the commonalities are really
high
but i have no idea and it's quite
frustrating and why
some of these items get politicized and
people start going at each other's
throats when it makes
no sense but one thing on your point
about people deciding i'm gonna go to
waiting or i'm gonna go spring break
um i think they take ownership of their
health
and particularly it represents their own
physical appearance in a way that they
may not
otherwise but what they do in that short
period isn't effectively sustainable
for them so i think embracing this
principle
no shortcuts no hacks it's the daily
habits
that ultimately will get you there and
you don't actually need to do too much
to end up with a very very different
health outcome
and in particular with sort of physical
appearance
it's surprisingly easy to maintain a
relatively
low body fat percentage and a reasonable
amount of muscle
with not a huge amount of effort like
the actual amount required to do that is
far far less than people think if you're
you're lining up those
different buckets and just like you're
saying the sleepy eight hours the
drink enough water the consistent bed
just
ownership around eating a bit more
cleanly
still have your beloved dominoes but
maybe it's not dinner every day
and maybe it's just on the weekends just
these little things has done
consistently add up i mean no one gets
to 70
and dies because of what they did when
they were 69 it's the cumulative
insults that are just part of uh
continually man so i think
with this growing interest both from our
incredible baby boomer population where
we're looking at
the ride off of and the biggest ride off
of intellectual capital
uh that the earth has just ever seen as
this group of people march towards
alzheimer's and dementia and all sorts
of craziness
i think more and more people in that
group are taking more and more ownership
which is wonderful and more people are
interested in
a happier life and not wasting their
life
and they're realizing that that means
owning some of these different pieces as
opposed to just saying that maybe
they're important actually taking steps
around ownership of
the different pieces so i applaud you
man for moving from the
the the bear and burger only nutrition
piece to
like focus i mean sleep is the big daddy
man as well
yeah it feels like um
there's also this uh desire to go from
uh if you use that spectrum or that kind
of uh you know green to red
um a lever that you described earlier a
lot of people are in the red
right so they don't sleep enough they
don't eat healthy they don't exercise
they don't you know whatever
uh stay up late on the computer all that
kind of stuff and
everyone tries to go from the red all
the way to the dark green
right it's like okay i'm gonna do
everything all at once and i think that
just
we know that uh changing habits right
it's very hard to change everything all
at once and so maybe talk a little bit
um as you've seen people uh who are
customers of athletic greens and kind of
transform over time
how exactly do you see the most
successful people like the people who
really do
make uh kind of long-term sustainable
change and
go from you know really bad to uh to
really good
what do they do like what what can
people do at home
um in terms of affecting that change
so it's a good question and typically it
comes down to which three key
groups of where someone more aligns that
effort say
athletic population they're already
exercising a lot they just typically
might not have been doing the right
things and the right doses and also
when you start to over exercise there is
absolutely a trade-off between health
and performance that
i think they become aware of and again
is typically take more ownership of the
different pieces that really matter
in the high performer hard charging
taipei pumps of the world
that is literally they are they want the
best they want it now they want it easy
they won't want it simple they want to
understand it
they typically are the crowd that are
looking for the hack or the secret sauce
that allows them to continue to be
maniacs in their life
but do as little as possible and i think
as they
take steps towards a healthier outcome
in one area they they tend to
consistently take
one or other or more steps around other
areas
and one of the coolest things i've seen
is
groups like you know that that sort of
hard charger high achiever group is
starting to realize that
sleep is cool and
because i've been saying food is first
sleep
sun exposure community for 10 years and
now that
that people are pulling out the aura or
the whoops and measuring their sleep and
it's starting to become cool
[Music]
like that that piece alone is just so
huge for that particular population
because they tend to just overclock
on the burn right they're just taking
the
they're taking the deposits out of the
bank account just
way too much and then the the last group
the health group
typically um these folks
are they could be anywhere in this
journey from
i just want to not feel sad every time i
walk past the mirror which is something
like i've
as a personal trainer for a while this
is brutal but it's also amazing when you
get someone to look in the mirror and go
i'm really happy with how i look in the
mirror it's one of the biggest
confidence turnarounds that you can you
can be a part of so i think
when people come in on that journey i
don't mind where anyone comes in
all i ask is that you're taking
ownership for your health
and you're not looking for a silver
bullet and
yeah i found the best adopting key
habits you don't want to slam everyone
with all the habits all at once it's one
of the key habits
that we can start to move the needle on
and typically man
the biggest one is like for the absolute
bottom bones beginner typically
really struggling with with body fat
massively inflamed don't move enough is
it would be do something that makes you
feel uncontrolled empowered
drink water go for a walk and try to get
an hours more sleep a night i'd just
start with
those three things and if we're part of
that great but i always tell them if you
have the choice
um for budgetary reasons or whatever
other reason then
focus on food first like get get the
whole food in first
got it so that middle bucket that the
kind of you know hard chargers that
usually describe them that's probably
most of the people who listen to this
podcast that's the category that they're
most likely to be in
walk us through uh one
you mentioned a whole bunch of what i'll
just call kind of analytics driven
technology right so whether it's you put
it on your wrist it's
on your bed uh it's on your phone in
some sort of software
whatever it ends up being what
is the importance of that stuff or do
you feel like some of that is
over rotation on trying to measure like
the really finite stuff but people are
still missing
uh kind of the big picture stuff like
how do you look at those as uh ways to
augment
uh change for somebody i think to the
degree that it gives
if you're going to do any of the
quantified self pieces i think
ultimately it needs to empower you
and people can go down a rabbit hole
pretty quickly and it should also give
you information that you
probably you may have understood it
to some degree without it but it does
give you actionable insights around
oh my god uh look at that and i think
for this group
the like a pedometer this is counting
how many steps you do that's great but
it's relatively simple you kind of know
if you've moved around
to some degree although i think it can
be great to look at that
um so take like the past six weeks where
i've had a tummy bug like my
average steps per day went from 12 000
to like under 2 000
and that's not okay so just
just the consistent again the consistent
habits piece so if you take the hard
charges
uh i would love them to be tracking
uh their sleep not because i think that
they need to track the sleep but the
degree of ownership and responsibility
that they will take
when they start tracking their sleep
will it'll be slapping them right in the
face that
hey man uh you said at that screen you
crushed two last red wine
at 10 pm looked at the screen till 11
and woke up at 5 30 or 6 you compare
that to
you finished work at five or six went
for a walk with your
lovely lovely wife chilled out
socialized ate early and just did
nothing like stimulatory for the last
two or three hours
and do that for a week and start to go
holy [ __ ] like man do i feel better
um i'm waking up feeling like a rock
star
or my libido starting to come back all
sorts of things will start to line up
when when people take those so i
i go back and forth because there are
some people who go way down the rabbit
hole man and
they're always looking for the little
the little the different hack the
different this a different that
but i think the key around this piece is
taking ownership
uh making some things non-negotiable and
even for me i am definitely in that
category
as well and just over the last three or
four years has
just made the sleep piece non-negotiable
so obviously if you're flying
uh or doing something else you try not
to get on the radars if you have to so
be it but just
start to build in this defend your sleep
habit and make this piece
to something you own left right and
center and just watch the magic happen
when you go to that eight hours
consistent every night as a habit man
that literally smokes just about
everything other than the stress
piece yeah and another key piece i think
is uh cheat meals right i think everyone
loves to uh to talk about them because
it's the
it's the splurge right it's the thing
that you get to do that
uh you feel like you're almost rewarding
yourself to some weird thing
um obviously every saturday i'm eating
dominoes uh
which is kind of like literally i look
forward to saturdays for that specific
reason
uh but talk about in general you know is
this
uh you gotta do the core things
right 50 of the time 75 percent of time
100 of the time like
how important is it to be perfect all
the time versus
you know kind of pre-planned uh
diversions from the plan as long as you
get back on to it
it's a really good question man so if
you look at those different buckets and
we can flip it into
a business setup so say if we're looking
at contribution management by channel
which
i have a direct with consumer business
it's my preferred management tool for
looking at how we're performing and you
just consider
okay how do we go around customer
acquisition
on facebook instagram youtube whatever
and you have these different columns
that all kind of line up
and you can look at these and go net net
um
we're we're doing great but there might
be a few of these pieces that are
getting crushed that are pulling down
uh the rest of the ship so to speak and
i think when you start to consider that
that red or green um that needle marker
as we discussed earlier
if you are consistently getting crushed
in any one of those areas you need to go
really clean and beautifully in some of
the other areas
so to answer your question about what's
it like to have this thing to look
forward and the cheat meals i'm quite
pro
the cheat meal i'm not pro when it gets
crazy out of hand or it goes from being
this
um like epic planned over
a month uh line up and then people do it
and they realize
that they've been great for a month and
nothing really happens because of that
one insult it was
just whatever and so you find that the
next one happens
not a month away but seven days away and
the next one and back they go to the old
habits i think that's one
one piece the other thing is to
understand i love pizza pizza with my
nemesis food for years man we should do
a i i'm
really allergic to wheat it turns out so
i have to always search the world for
the best gluten-free pizza
but it used to be a piece i my saturday
uh it was both carbury feed typically
unless i was training really hard in
which case
my my carb bolus during the week was was
much higher but typically
i tried to combine a so-called cheat day
with a carb refeed because i was going
pretty low carbohydrate the rest of the
week and i tended to feel miserable for
days and days afterwards but my two
nemesis foods were the pizza
and what you guys called dim sum what
we'd call yamcha back in new zealand
those two things i got the point that
lunch time i'd rock up to my restaurant
favorite restaurant auckland there'd be
a queue of like 100 people
uh in in line the manager would see me
march me pass the line and sit me down
because i would smash
so much dim sum that i was like the
ultimate
dollars per table that they've just ever
experienced and they didn't know man
that i've been building up for this for
a week so i was training like maniac
and then nighttime would be a pizza that
was kind of my my role
then i found out that this is that 9010
principle that i mentioned so
if all your various buckets are kind of
more or less in the green occasionally
going what into the red
is no real big deal at all i'd almost
suggest that you
do so much in the green so often that
you don't even worry about planning the
cheat meal like when it happens it
happens you don't worry you just
enjoy it and just get straight back on
the wagon that would be
a much healthier adoption of of this
piece but take
for me i am really intolerant to wheat
and
that one dose the rest of the week i
didn't eat any wheat but that one dose a
week was enough to really mess me up
and uh you know if i'd gone my whole
life
knowing that i actually shouldn't be
eating this particular food
for me because for me it inflamed me and
tore up my gut and everything else then
my life would be quite different
health-wise i think and so it's just
that understanding that
there's that saying everything in
moderation including moderation and
but as long as those things are in green
and when you're stepping across and
you're having things that aren't
necessarily like in green
in that bucket at that moment it's no
real drama at all
for someone who can tolerate it man it
might mean you toast them you
total the pizza whatever and it could be
a social dynamic tied to that that net
net is
so much more positive than the little
bit of insult you may do for you
with the pizza whereas i would do a lot
to to make it
completely worthwhile i think that
social pieces
and maybe it's something that happens
when you go outside the drinking maybe
without going too crazy this is one
night a week where you're already
getting together with your buddies or
your family or whatever
and your your italian extraction so i
imagine family gatherings are still
pretty epic
and so what you smash a bit of alcohol
and
a whole ton of pizza and pasta in that
moment but the social dynamic
this net net is a positive for you and
just not even worrying about it probably
um does better for a lot of people so
the answer to that question man is it
depends unfortunately it's the case for
nearly everything in health and
nutrition
that's perfectly fine uh one of the
areas i'm really interested in
is obviously with the covid19 stuff uh
there's tons of talk about
drugs and vaccines and kind of all this
uh stuff that may or may not happen
and you know i'm not a scientist so i
kind of just say look we'll see what the
science has come up with
uh but there are things that it appears
that people can do to boost their immune
system in general right so not
necessarily saying hey
we're going to uh prevent the spread of
a virus because i've loosened my immune
system but just
general good health type of stuff
and so talk a little bit about how you
think of
boosting the immune system and then also
uh one thing you've mentioned a couple
of times is
sunlight and kind of the impact that um
that can have on people that they may
not realize
yeah so i think to it's interesting man
because in january every year
people have their new year's resolutions
and anyone with a health and fitness
related business
has their bumper bump a month or two and
what happened with covert kicking in is
we had five or six januaries back to
back
and rather than put ourselves on the
back and go great job
we just realized it's people taking more
ownership of
their health and one of those pieces
obviously is the immunity piece
and hopefully you know there's a silver
lining and some of the covert stuff that
people taking there's more awareness
about metabolic health and
the daily inputs and habits and things
that ultimately drive a healthy outcome
but from an immunity piece if you are
not in the green across the majority of
all those different buckets and think
that you're going to suddenly take
uh some zinc some vitamin c and
and just rock it out but you you're
dreaming right your your body works
together synergistically it's a system
and
you you definitely want to be in the
green uh
for if you're trying to optimize your
immunity and then there are some things
that can boost
immunity and i think sleep clean
nutrition
something like our product you don't
want to promote it too much but it does
a great job of covering those bases
and then the vitamin d piece and we we
provide a vitamin d
but i'm much like this oral there's
benefits to oral vitamin d
but i much prefer folks at this
time of year there is no excuse unless
you're just locked in an office and just
can't get out
to get your vitamin d from sun exposure
and that's not saying you go out and
turn yourself into a
red lobster right or like the french
call the english roast beef
because they come in every year sit on
the beach and go bright pink like the
color of roast beef
and don't do that that that will not
result in a positive outcome but
incremental intelligent sun exposure
both getting light on your eyes and also
our bodies are really well equipped to
synthesize vitamin d
from skin to sun exposure
to me makes the most sense and if you
can't do that
then and only then do you look to
supplement with
oral vitamin d but i would much much
rather from all the different health
elements of being outdoors getting a
light in your eyes the photosensitivity
the immune boosting benefits are massive
and that like that bucket just put that
one solidly in the green particularly in
the middle
of of of summer man there's
there's no there's no real reason why
you shouldn't go and do that
yeah makes a lot of sense um let's talk
a little bit about
uh when people take athletic greens what
exactly are they putting in their body
green gold uh no man
[Laughter]
so you have you have various parts of
the body work in different ways and you
have like i said you can put something
in your mouth
and you could not be putting enough in
your mouth or you could not be absorbing
it properly or could be misusing
something in your body so
inherently we're giving you a bolus of
micronutrients that are
with a ton of so-called phytonutrients
and plant nutrients
massively in one place along with and
in the forms that your body uh things
that will help you absorb it so that's
everything from
we have probiotics we have digestive
enzymes we have
prebiotics we have the various cofactors
and other things that are present in
food that your body recognizes inbound
vitamins minerals as food and sucks them
over so that's the
in the in the tube and then absorbed
piece and then we have
gentle touches uh that sort of have
secondary effects on improving bodily
function
with a view towards look get all your
green buckets lined up
absolutely own that food piece yourself
there's no silver
bullet i know i've mentioned it a lot
man but i do it's important to me that
people get it
and then give yourself this daily
nutritional insurance piece which is
sort of a hedge that
maybe you're not getting in enough maybe
not absorbing it properly
or maybe for any number of reasons your
body is not processing
uh some of those micronutrients and the
goal is sort of healthy cells if you
think about it at the end of the day
it's
it's what you absorb that really matters
it's how you use it and it's healthy
cells is the outcome and that is
something that
consistently it's the habit piece again
it's
day in day out consistent give your body
a caress
put a deposit in instead of withdrawal
into this
spectacular machine that is your body
and just do it consistently
so that that is kind of how it works man
it's
it's a it's a plant-based based product
but it's just got so much nutrition in
one place
uh that it sort of acts as a hedge
against any one of those three pieces
we spent a bunch of time talking about
kind of the health and wellness aspect
of what you guys do
uh i don't want people to think that
this is a small business you've done a
fantastic job of building a very large
business
talk a little bit about kind of the
business side of what you're doing in
terms of
you started you know a number of years
ago and kind of how the business has
grown over time and really what's driven
that growth
to build athletic brains into what it is
today
yeah thanks man the
and inherently when i when i came up
with the idea to formulate this
ultimate all-in-one take it daily and be
done
i idea i i thought i'm an athletic guy
this is for an athletic group of people
um those who are already taking massive
ownership around the health and it's a
grains based powder so i'm going to call
athletic greens and off we go so
i merely march to the us and promptly
burnt through all the money i'd raised
royally pissed off
my then investor and business partner as
i found out it's actually really
freaking hard to sell stuff but
i knew that what we built was um
i wanted to go direct to consumer we
didn't have the margin to make retail
work we in fact the first two advisors i
said
said you just flat out don't have the
margin to make this work retail
online anywhere because i effectively
super bundled and
over engineered a product without
actually testing this is something the
market was willing to pay for
it was something i was willing to pay
for but it was
uniquely designed ultimately to be sold
around a subscription direct to consumer
model and
literally having run out of money and
sleeping on couches and
parting ways with my investor and having
a pretty challenging time
uh emotionally just dealing with
not feeling sorry for myself that your
life is kind of crap i went all in on
this focus on look
when do i have the biggest impact in the
universe when
uh when can i most help people and how
could this all work and i realize i want
to work
off the recommendations of other people
who are
telling folks to come and adopt this as
a habit and it's that habit adoption
so when people come in adopt it as a
habit
and they are in one of those sort of
three buckets that i mentioned and
obviously can afford us we are we are a
premium price product we actually had
the lowest margins in
supplement land but what we found is
that
these folks would would stick and stick
and stick so
it would be really really hard to
require the right customer it's
very hard to do so profitably at the
best of times but
harder for us because we don't really
have the margins but when the right
person comes
they tend to stay with us for a long
time and they trust us
to continue to keep up to date on the
science
and everything else to evolve this if
you're going to take one thing
and make it this thing and we're on the
53rd uh edition of this product which is
about to come out which is pretty cool
so
i think that for those people the fact
that they stick around long enough
despite the fact i suck at marketing i
suck at nomenclature i made so many
mistakes
but the fact that we are something
that's really good for people really
good for the universe
has allowed us to attract really good
quality people to the team
and when customers come for the right
reason like i said silver bullet is not
us
then and this is the habit that kind of
matches with
with them then they they stick and that
allows us to make a business work
that wouldn't have worked under any
other condition because of the margins
so i i look at what some of these folks
are doing with various data companies
where they're trying to
just throw money into into acquisition
and feel like they can sort of buy
themselves away to a brand without
ultimately solving problems for
customers that
customers want to be solved and
i think the investment world is waking
up to maybe this wasn't such a good idea
to spend a dollar and get 85 cents back
and hope
customers would come back but like
anything else you're either adding value
you're solving a problem or you're not
and it's that
customer experience is the key driver
and we are not in
all things to all people product we are
literally for those in those three
buckets who want the absolute best
um that that's our that's our person and
when they come in
they stick so it's multiple years of
those people sticking around and saying
nice things
that have led to us having the small
amount of success if it's some pretty
epic people on this podcast man so we're
we're a little minnow compared to some
of your guests but we have
ambitions to leave a nice dent in the
universe
well i think part of this is um the
focus on acquisition versus retention
right and ultimately for something like
this uh i
always think of um whether it's
something like the air pods or it's a
food and uh kind of wellness supplement
anything that you put
in your body or near your body is a very
intimate experience for people
right and you're probably one of the
most intimate wishes
basically the value proposition is
you're going to drink this every single
day
and so there's not much margin of error
in terms of
you know if it tastes great three days
but it tastes bad you know
the other four days of the week that's
not good enough right and so it's got to
have kind of the consistent
um value that is seen in the eyes of the
customer and that ultimately
leads that retention um and then it's
interesting to hear you kind of talk
about you know by not having
really large margins um you really are
dependent on the retention
right over long periods of time and and
so talk maybe a little bit about um you
know from a metric standpoint like how
do you think about
uh retention and what's successful and
what's not right some people who are
listening to this
uh may be um like software engineers or
entrepreneurs who probably think of it
differently than you would with physical
products so how do you think about that
retention
and kind of what works for you guys it's
not that different from
folks who have say a sas business and
that
i mean look we you mentioned taste some
people are going to love our taste we
work so hard
on making what looks like green sewage
water taste good without compromising
and it was really hard and
but i think we've done a great job but
again for some people it's just like you
know what
not not interested in this piece or i
don't want to have a green powder or
it's not matching
for me or i want to feel more energy
i'll go back to red but whatever
it's not remember when they come for the
right reason there's an inflection point
which is pretty common
in the physical product space at or
around that
fourth order um effective
churn or drop-off changes dynamically
and what what you've gotten to is the
people who match
to yeah this habit is is part of who i
am and going forward i see the value in
continuing it
and there are others that come and go
come and go come and go but inherently
it's just understanding we can't go
everywhere
i can't compete with a lot of these
people on acquisition span we're a
bootstrap
company the the whole piece for us
is how do we make our customers think
they'd be crazy to go
anywhere else and really look after them
from a customer experience
standpoint and i think we do
a once someone's a customer of us i
think we do a great job of delivering a
great experience but like i said it's
not
not for everyone we've tried in the past
to
be more aggressive in the throttle and
realize we acquired a whole lot of
wrong people and i think your whole
point that people focus on the
acquisition piece instead of
their attention piece does not work in
our margin
environment and it just allowed us to
focus on
driving enough failure in the customer
experience that once people come for the
right reasons have adopted that habit
which was way harder before when no one
was smashing a green powder
whereas now anyone instagram account
will see their favorite health and
fitness bunny
smashing green green drinks left right
and center even though we're not
technically a green drink but the habit
is the cultural habit
around this new behavior is definitely
moved to our favor but
but yeah man it's just a focus on right
customer don't overpay
take that slower growth and and look
after
people and again i'm not trying to be
all things to
to everyone we're not going to come out
with 400 skus
and we're going deep on on that one
value prop which is if you're going to
take one thing to feel awesome every day
take this and i think does that focus on
on the retention piece and that customer
life cycle piece
has actually led us to be very lean very
efficient very capital efficient
and we have the hot we have the most
horrible supply chain man we have
well over 75 ingredients some of them
are very specialized
access to them is difficult uh
controlling the sourcing pieces is
actually one of our key
ip pieces but we have this brutal cash
flow cycle so that
that itself has led to a uh
a focus on acquiring the right customers
and then keeping them happy but
that compounds on itself man in
subscription billing
i think it was edison said compounding
interest is the eighth winner of the
world
you probably say bitcoin is the eighth
wonder of the world i'd probably go in
for
uh subscription billing because as long
as someone comes in the right reason and
there and they're happy to be there
again next month
you can make a heck of a lot of errors
this month and live to live to tell the
tale next month because that customer
came back
and look man i i think understanding
that if you want to be in business
you want to be in the reorder business
is the biggest failing i see most
of the d2c players jump in and just ruin
stuff with and you can make a ton of
money by just out executing everyone at
the acquisition piece and keep people
long enough that it drives
enough profitability and you can get
really big but there are some players
out there man making tons of cash
but are they building the business i
believe is the
what i want to build now not not really
not at all
that makes a lot of sense what's the
biggest lesson you've learned in
building the company from like a
management standpoint
right is you've been very successful but
i think that
there's a lot of kind of business
tactics lessons but from a
building a company building a culture um
you know marketing etc
you know as the founder of the business
what's the biggest lesson that you had
to learn
and i'd learnt them all i am more stupid
than i realized is the biggest lesson
i feel like i did a 100 meter sprint in
a 90 meter gym but not just once like
again
and again and again and again so i think
the biggest error was
i when i by the time i had athletic
greens as my sole focus
i was nearly five million dollars in
debt for another business that had gone
under
so i i realized i have to make or break
i'm not in a hurry
but whatever happens i can't die so i
think i
didn't sell a big enough vision early or
bring enough
real rock stars to the table earlier
like i almost over bootstrapped with
myself doing way too much for way too
long and if i was going to go back
and do it all again it's very easy i
would sell a much bigger vision and i
would bring
seriously powerful rock stars to the
table who have execution intelligence on
what we wanted to do
and we frequently attracted really smart
people but often with
absolutely no experience in what they
were then going to be asked to do and
sometimes that's an advantage because
someone comes up with a new different
way of doing things
but more more often than not you just
suffer as someone tries to figure
stuff out so those two pieces man the
bigger vision
and bring rockstars to the table early
except it makes sense and it also feels
like
um you know it's obvious today right but
uh it sounds like you are of the belief
that you have to go through the
challenges and obstacles in order to
learn those lessons
you just don't have the key i wish i
mean i i'm one of my biggest drivers
paul i'd be curious to hear what what
your
like more internal drivers are because
you're obviously very smart
very capable when you're doing what i
most admire people which is you're
literally
creating your own reality around what's
important to you
and i think it's one thing i most admire
about interesting people
is whether you're a painter an artist
an entrepreneur an investor like
yourself you're literally just creating
your own reality it empowers you and
adds value and does the things that you
want to do in the world so
i think for for me you have to go
through a certain amount of pain
you definitely want to be innovative and
be willing to take small punches in the
face to
figure out how things work i think what
you make non-negotiable
in any given business activity and end
in life is ultimately what drives
mastery like i've
despite one of those first guys the
table had taken a company to 350 million
dollars and offered
to turn around plug us into retail and
introduce us to every
um head buyer or ceo at every major mass
outfit in the us but i to make that off
to pull it off
he wanted to invest and i'd have to dumb
down the formulation to the point that
it gave us back
industry acceptable margins uh i said
i'm not going to
do it and just that sort of decision
around i just don't want to compromise
on the ultimate
customer experience around what we're
doing
it was very expensive made life really
tough but it's also the single biggest
smartest decision that we've ever made
that positive experience just slowly
compounds on itself and we want to build
a
brand that people love to talk about and
love to be a part of for a hundred years
that's
that's the ambition yeah i love that
it's always uh it's always the decisions
that uh
uh end up being the long-term ones that
usually pay off so that's awesome
i asked the same two questions to every
person who comes on and you'll get to
ask me a question to uh to finish up
uh the first is uh what is the most
important book that you've ever read
that's a good one man very recently i
read a book called essentialism by greg
mccowan okay uh
it is about the happiness that ensues
when one
truly focuses on what is ultimately most
important to them and eliminates
everything else
as absolutely brilliant book it speaks
to how i recommend you focus your time
how i recommend you
invest how what is good strategy for a
company
and i found that unbelievably uh
unbelievably useful it really spoke to
me at the moment when i sort of
was stepping back and thinking what
started the next three to five year
strategy as a
as a business so i loved that book as a
it's got to be top 10 lifetime and
not everyone resonates as much as i do
because i started saying this is the
best book i've read and throwing it
everywhere and
some people came back and said this is
amazing and others said yeah it sounds
like common sense and a tonic
and interestingly enough those who came
back and said it sounds like common
senses and tonic
are the ones who most need to hack away
uh parts of their life and some of these
people are really smart people and it's
been fascinating yeah that's all i i
love
uh books specifically because one it
tells you
uh it's the book the content but also
the time that somebody reads it right it
can have a huge impact on on the answer
uh and then um when you give it to
somebody it tells you a lot about where
they are
in terms of their reaction that's right
yeah so they said that's pretty cool
uh aliens believer or non-believer
100 believer why and typically man i'm
sitting here looking at i can't there's
a cloud on top of the hill
next to me here otherwise i'd show you
this epic green pyramid mountain
and so that that's that landed here
somehow but actually it didn't it's just
a rock formation
no why man just balance the
probabilities
is takes you to some 99 point something
percent likelihood you have to
someone who thinks scientifically around
the world has to have the balance of
probabilities
isn't the 100 but that last jump is
because
i think the universe is more interesting
if they're there
yeah i'm hoping so i'm hoping so we can
find them though
we i don't want them finding us let's go
find them well it depends who it is i
mean if they're like
related to that moroccan family who
helped me out i mean come on down
i think the bigger issue won't be if
they're there or not is that we exist in
the same
same time because i mean i don't know if
you've seen um
cosmos with neil degrasse tyson but
probably i don't watch much tv but
definitely
the winner of the covert tv season for
me has been cosmos which is a series on
itunes and he just it's about four or
five years old so maybe some of the
physics is dated but it's pretty cool
man he just talks
about the mix and match between this
amazing massive universe we have right
here
and that amazing monster universe we
have out there but
every time i saw that i kept thinking of
your big question on the aliens going
they must
they must this place is massive i
i tend to agree one question you have
for me to
finish up yeah so congratulations on
becoming a newlywed
what was it that made you realize this
is the girl for me um
i don't think there's one answer right
it's uh
it's so weird um think of it as a
a business partner to start with right
in terms of uh when you're picking a
business partner
uh what you end up picking is somebody
who
uh you get along with you have the same
mentality
you probably have complimentary skills
um you think that they are
uh determined persistent you know
they're reasonable there are sound
decisions
like there's all these things that go
into picking a business partner right
then when you're uh picking a wife right
uh it's all of that um like times uh you
know 100 000
x uh steroids right and um
it it really is uh one of these things
where
uh the first time we met it was just
very obvious i think to both of us
like we're gonna go like hang out more
and that person is unlike other people
that i've met
and you know i i could sit and try to
like pinpoint exactly what it was or
um you know what i thought frankly i
don't really
remember like walking away being like oh
it's because of this one quality that
this person has but it was just more of
um you know i spent my entire life
really living by one principle which is
the goal
is just to be happy right and if i do
something and i'm not happy
i literally just wake up one day and say
i'm done right and
people don't like that because it feels
very um
kind of flighty right but at the same
time i i just
uh i always think of um have you ever
seen a movie uh i think it's called in
time with uh justin timberlake yes
right where he's got like the time on
your arm and basically when the time
runs out you die
right yeah and uh and it's a uh
you know it's not an a plus uh acting
movie right so if you're a cinematic
expert it's probably not the one that
you're gonna
gravitate towards uh but the message of
the movie is
very much you know the rich people have
all the time right the poor people don't
have time
um and basically they go to work and
they're literally given time
uh to kind of extend to the next time
that they go to work
and so you just like there's a lot of
metaphors in that movie that i think are
really interesting because what it
reminds you is
uh ultimately like that is the currency
right is
time uh it's who do you want to spend
your time with what do you want to spend
your time doing like all of these things
are
important and uh i think planet and i
just
you know over the years it was very
obvious like we are
super super aligned on you know all of
the important things
uh if you asked her this question she
would say uh we have
different skill sets i don't know if she
would call them complimentary i probably
annoy the hell out of her sometimes
and all the normal stuff but uh i think
that's really it right it's just
uh you know finding the person that um
yeah you genuinely feel like hey this is
my best friend
and uh we think similarly we
have the same types of goals and uh
we're happy together
right that was a pretty slow answer for
a bitcoiner who believes in aliens man
well done well i know she's gonna watch
this so i gotta say all the right things
right no you you crushed it man you're
looking good for saturday night but my
dad always said to me your single
biggest decision in life is gonna be who
that partner and he's been a lifelong
mentor for me and i was lucky to grow up
in a family dynamic where my parents
would very much love my my whole life so
i always admire folks like i said who
create their own reality men i think
that was an outstanding answer on
choosing the right partner because
you want a happy life go go make it
happen
absolutely i'm a big believer that you
can create the world that you want
where can we send uh where can we send
people to find you on the internet uh
and find out more about athletic greens
if they want to uh to try it out sure
man i
don't really tweet i have a twitter
account but i don't really use it much
but athletic greens is at
athleticgreens.com
but we're like anyone wants to come give
us a try he wants to take that ownership
and realize
there's no silver bullet it's the habits
that count come come play we'd love to
have you but any questions if you want
to go
uh chris the kiwi at christakiwi on
twitter i'll respond to anything you
guys fire up that's cool
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for doing this you've built a an
amazing company and
we'll have to do this again as you guys
keep pushing forward
thanks pompa appreciate the friendship
man i really appreciate you having me on
and thank you for your kind words
absolutely